so what do you think happens when
someone who is part of this uber woke
culture mm-hmm
gets canceled themself what do you think
their immediate reaction would be I
think I think I might know what you're
talking about do you think they would
cry yeah are you I'm I'm fighting for
you job oh I wasn't even thinking about
this I was thinking about Alyssa Milano
what she what was that what happened
well you don't even know no okay so she
did Snookie yeah Jersey Shore yeah whoo
she just you know it was like a really
really dark tan yeah yes it wasn't
necessarily blackface it's like a Trump
Dan yeah yeah and they were like wow how
dare you like look let's cancel her and
she's just like she she went off on him
like look a-holes like it was Snooki ha
it was supposed to be funny it's like oh
it's you you're going for comedy that's
nice when did she do that I don't know
it's been old old video it's been going
around is she crying recently oh she's
no she was snapping at him she was like
was a long line I am me I don't know it
was there since I brought this funny
stuff how was reference a specific I
know are you this rude talking about
let's talk about this oh this lady she's
crying oh mylanta I don't even know if
she's really crying oh yo I think she's
a sociopath
yeah because yeah because if you watch
her crying video she goes she goes from
crying into she goes but I won't stop
fighting for justice and it was like
like well what you're a joke so this is
a story about let's break it down you
maybe have heard about this Harvard grad
said she lost her Deloitte job after
tick tock joke threatening to stab
anyone who says all lives matter it was
a dumb joke I saw I saw the original
video it was a dumb joke it was a dumb
joke
she was trying to make a point that if
she stabbed you and then you complained
about it she would say her paper cut was
just as important right but all that
mattered is the clip was going viral if
a person I'm a stab you and then she's
like head-butting the camera or whatever
which is like some kind of meme
something yeah and then she got fired
and then all the comments were all lives
matter all lives matter or matter and
then she was like for legal reasons I
have to say this was a joke like his too
late it's too late sorry girl so here's
I guess the son likes posting photos of
her crying right I don't believe she's
actually crying though she because she's
milking it for all it's worth I've lost
my job they're supposed to be on my side
but I won't stop fighting for justice
things like brave you turn that around
real quick yeah yeah I called she's just
making more videos and the more you know
now she's gonna make another video about
this about everybody else
mm-hmm so so there's kind of a
controversy going around because at the
same time I take kind of a controversy
but I'm seeing some people talk about
this stefan molyneux got banned from
YouTube right yeah and I don't know the
exact reason because I don't follow him
I don't really know what his whole thing
is but he's accused of being far-right
and holding like supremacist views or
something
apparently he says it's not true and the
left always well you know here's the
problem outside us right now
first and foremost I'm not super
familiar with the stefan molyneux his
work I mean neither am i no no I briefly
met him in passing one time while I was
in LA and it was like a ten second thing
I was like oh yes you're stefan molyneux
nice to meet you does it okay not seen
any of his videos the left accuses a
little whole bunch of the worst of the
worst the only problem is they accuse
everybody of it yeah so the only
assumption I can make as he probably
wasn't what there's a crying wolf man
but it's also that there's other people
on Twitter who are saying the
accusations against him are completely
false but it got his channel terminated
someone else who defend him got their
channel terminated - Wow yeah so they're
like you better be careful about what
you say about this guy
don't say anything positive I guess but
the the issue right now is there's a lot
of people actually defending this woman
who's crying because canceled culture is
stupid because it's very very stupid it
is yeah she should not have lost her job
because she said a stupid joke that was
obviously her trying to be edgy agreed
but she also look man if you if you walk
into your field and you throw about
apple seeds
you can't complain when apple trees grow
so I have a nice I have a point because
I mildly disagree with him here I think
that she has shown herself to be
impulsive wildly emotionally
manipulative extremely cunning and
dishonest and I think that any company
would be well within their rights to say
you are a risk that we are not ready to
take and I don't think that's fair
because I think it was just a joke but I
think they had every right oh you know
who else got fired I just found out the
husband of that lady who pulled a gun on
that yes fired he got fired from his job
at Oakland University in Rochester
Michigan Wow yep good we did it why is
this good because the look man if people
can't stand up for themselves if you're
not going to if people gonna you need to
defend yourself you need do the right
thing yeah you know I saw someone just
super chatted they're like you know good
on Adam he's actually giving me more of
a like I I'm inspired to speak my mind
yeah I am calling my friends out I'm
calling people I mean I don't care I'm
calling anyone out if you see if I see
it I am calling you out on it it doesn't
matter and I'm gonna have a conversation
you you probably won't like it and I
don't care if you don't like it or not
but I'm gonna have that conversation
with you people need to start standing
up right because we keep talking about
it the people on the Left they're super
loud they don't have jobs to go through
there just screeching the loudest right
now we have to screech as loud as they
are it's like you know what I will I
will be a loud buzz in your ear I'm
gonna tell me I'm you're gonna announce
the things that I believe really well
and bad with myself up there's a couple
things here with this weird you know
this woman in stuff like this mm-hmm
it's that because regular people aren't
speaking up the perception among many
people is that the hip cool culture the
acceptable culture is this yep exactly
goes all the big brands are doing it all
the celebrities are doing it and so
there's actually I actually have a funny
story because I was always arguing with
someone who I would I would say is you
know a longtime longtime friend of mine
and they're saying a bunch of things
about me being biased and you know how
their memes are better than me and stuff
like that and how like they think how
it's so sad because their perspective is
they're on the side of the mainstream
right and so they're like you've become
like weirdo fringe conspiracy guy dude
and I was like look what happened to you
and I was like do you do you read the
news
you actually know what's going on nope
what makes you think that I'm on the
outside and you're on the inside right
and so then I explained to him I was
like you realize I've been on one of the
biggest podcast in the world multiple
times now three times in the past year
that I've been hanging out with famous
pro skateboarders musicians and then and
then and then guess what his attitude
became mm-hmm oh really oh I mean oh wow
that's really cool man
all of a sudden who is really move a
they a lot of people believe that the
mainstream is this weird brand brand is
very concerned about social issue and we
know that group of people need to be
protected yeah that's what they think
it's real life for all of pride they had
the flag next day which all gone yeah
you got her one of the most famous pro
skateboarders in the world mm-hmm rock
stars and these are people who hit me up
and they're like yo do to love the show
and I'm like I really do appreciate it
man I wish these people would speak up
more right and you don't got to be mean
he's gonna calm irrational say look man
I'm not down with this weird stuff I
think it's racist exactly that's how
that's how I've been doing it it's like
look it's not I'm not trying to rag on
you I'm not trying to berate you for
your beliefs I'm giving you my opinion
and backing it up with actual things
that are happening because you're giving
me your opinion backed up by other
opinions it's it's well for me it's it's
more of an issue of who they perceive to
be cool I'm socially acceptable it's a
good point and so when they think like
you know when they when they when they
live off of memes and they think what we
do for instance must not be popular
right and then I say things to them
about like metrics versus guests and
like prominence and all sudden their
tune changes realizing wait a minute am
I on the wrong side uh-oh our live at
ease are we the baddies and I'll say to
them I'll look bro you know like there
are people I grew up skateboarding with
who had aspirations of being the biggest
pro skaters in the world and then
they're posting this ridiculous zealous
fanaticism you know they're mean nasty
people
they're shrieking they're they're
engaging in canceled culture and then I
say do you think you know
pro skateboarder you know X&Y would want
to hang out with you when you do this
stuff cut a sum I know for a fact they
wouldn't you know why because I talked
to them yeah and they're like well
really you do yeah I do and I'm hanging
out I'm hanging out a party with with
like some high profile musicians and
rock stars and I'm not saying it to brag
man I'm letting you know that there are
regular people in this country who are
scared of the weird shocking nonsense
that's going on yeah and there's a
reason why people want to listen to a
show like mine one listen to YouTube
videos like mine old one listen to say
Joe Rogan for instance yeah you know
he's famous right and also their tune
starts changing and they start to think
themselves oh maybe I'm the weirdo maybe
this stuff is weird and unfun and nobody
wants to be involved in it now of course
there are some you see these celebrities
but take a look at what happens with
these celebrities like what was that
what was the I take responsibility
that's embarassing that video everyone
made fun of them even the left so well
first it was the imagine song video that
went around hurt so much and then I take
responsibility it was kind of like that
2.0 and it was equally cringy and bad
and so you have all these celebrities
constantly trying to inject themselves
in this way or the prince and it's not
fun what that [ __ ] is he even a prince
anymore someone said something that I
cracked up laughing someone said it
looked like a hostage video like he was
speaking everyone was saying that like
someone like said had a gun you know
behind the camera yeah like read read
this so cancel the Queen right it's like
if you really believe this so you you're
here like this this video is basically
Prince Harry talking about how
institutional racism is bad
there is nothing more institutionally
racist than hereditary monarchies so how
about we have the Queen step down and
you can appoint a black Asian or
minority ethnic or what it was in Middle
East isn't Middle Eastern or minority
ethnic minority I think you could
appoint to that as your queen I would
nominate Beyonce oh yeah she said she's
already the queen rise the Queen
everybody loves her no how about we ask
the good people of the United Kingdom if
they would like to see the Queen step
down because Prince Harry's
certainly thinks that institutionalizes
was a problem I know the answers gonna
be
Fe yeah Queen yeah but but I was talking
to some some British friends of mine and
I made that point and it's like they
love the Queen you know they do could
you imagine them being like well the
queen is white and the monarchy is
literally it's beyond institutional
racism but we're talking about like a
single single bloodline so like you
don't eat you could eat there's just you
know never gonna happen
well I guess technically Harry married
Megan Markel I guess but and she's great
yeah but didn't they renounce their
royalty or something and moved to
California to be celebrities can you
appoint a queen like I'm a no and one
wanted the US government to give them
security
let's have affirmative action in the
royal family why not
I mean does she really do anything at
this point I don't know she is the head
of state
you know Sweden King yeah yeah what do
they do they figure heads right yeah
they're not it's not like the government
it's kind of like I think I think they
are they just get to be rich forever
yeah yeah yeah they get to be rich
forever
yeah um that's basically like I I know
that they have royal duties and
apparently was that got the sprits why
is they're starting to fight and I just
wanna you gotta give the cat you got it
you got to spritz the cat's when they're
causing trouble cats Brisco keep the
peace so there are two cats and Adam is
spritzing them because that's what you
do
I can't well Betsy was was biting him
and it's like were they playing and did
you just break up their play fight they
weren't making noise I don't know their
why I saw you didn't see it right I saw
it I have the I have the proof here are
you oppressing the cat's oh my god what
you just did all pets are slaves are I
want you to I want you to imagine
everyone listening Adam with a large
fire hose spraying these poor I've been
poor cats I I asked what kind of gun I
should use a lot of people did a squirt
gun yeah for what what and I chose it
yes sir
whoa whoa whoa sorry yes rich water
legally I know I have no
I have no trigger discipline I got it
learning you gotta keep when you oh it's
more did you just muzzle me and you
gotta keep your finger off the trigger
until you're ready and so the first rule
of the spritz bottle is always treated
spritz bottles if it if it has water
second rule is always keep it pointed
down keep your finger off the trigger
and don't point it at anything you don't
want to spritz like a camera what were
we just talking about no I thought we
were talking about something important
totally la how we're talking about this
crazy mana queen canceling uh
celebrities Sweden's Queen speaking up
for stuff that they why are we putting
them out as tool yeah basically
I don't know good a wild and crazy life
outside I'll tell you I have lived a
while you know what me too we also we've
had some interesting stuff wounded we
would have done work more than once
didn't we yeah twice G Anya
Christina's like I know I went to
Copenhagen too many times we could
release that video now I'm not in
college right on oh really yeah yeah
buried in the basement because you can
Kristiania Kristiania is the autonomous
zone of Denmark and that's what they
were basically trying to like emulate
yeah but it's been around since the 70s
and they actually help they do it yeah
yeah but it's more of a fun well really
what happened was this these buildings
were crumbling it was an old military
installation of barracks and the city
didn't want to do anything so a bunch of
hippies moved in and started fixing
everything okay and fixed it up and
turned the whole complex essentially
into their new spot and they're like
this is our zone and they've they've
made it their own
and yeah yeah yeah Gardens we went yeah
awesome okay but not to like start
talking about Christian or anything but
I'm totally down though you know what
when I mentioned like I've done a bunch
of crazy things in my life mm-hmm III
know all of these people I grew up with
and they really do think I know they
think I grew up with them they think
that they're part of the cool kids club
when they when name
this this new religion yeah so so they
start saying a bunch of dumb things on
Facebook I always approach them politely
and I'll say something like oh actually
you know like here's that here's the
data on this and they start going you
know guffawing and like me sure but I'm
part of the cool kids club like what are
you even doing like what happened to you
man are you even an influencer how many
followers do you have
it's not it's not even my said it's that
they're convinced that so so this is
really important too for people who
consider themselves to be like moderate
in the intellectual dark web type space
or conservative or whatever regular
people have been trained to view you as
a fringe outlier not a part of regular
America and that works so in their mind
if they want to be cool
Trump is bad right well if you were a
free-thinking individual you could come
to your own opinion like yeah but not
that bad right
sure like here's some things I like
about I'm here sometimes I don't like
about them come on let's be real you
know even even when I talked to the
average trump supporter they have
complaints yeah they have criticisms
yeah they have a lot of support for them
yeah and you know what whoever you vote
for I don't care I'm not gonna like put
you in a bracket in my brain that's
gonna be like well this person's just an
idiot that will vote for whoever it's
like I mean I'm gonna I have my opinions
on on what's going on I have my own
political views myself you know it's
like but don't come at don't put me in a
bracket if I'm an evil person you know
because of it it's like that's that's
ridiculous but would you vote for Stalin
no would you be friends with someone who
voted for Stalin probably not yeah
probably not
I thought we wouldn't be friends with
those people exactly so okay from from
the perspective of you know if you
wanted to vote for Biden mm-hmm
you want to what for Trump that's fine
because they're actually similar they
were thin the Overton Window right so
the issue is actually that if Stalin was
on the ticket I would not want to be
friends if anybody would vote for him
right agree I'd be like you're insane
this guy literally kills people yeah
that's how the far-left thinks right now
they think Trump is Hitler that's crazy
because they've gone insane and so now
I'm like I don't care if you vote for
Bernie or Biden or Trump I'm not a crazy
person and recognize you know you know
while Bernie's got a bunch of far left
Diaz he's like the furthest left of
what's acceptable in this country and
it's barely acceptable a lot of ways but
still acceptable to a lot of people yeah
like if someone said I want universal
health care you'd be like I don't think
that would work but you're not gonna
screech yeah if someone came out like
you know like Stalin came out he's like
I want to take all the land from the
farmers we'd be like whoa whoa we're
gonna kill everybody
yeah that's nuts so the problem right
now is the the the fanatic far-left
lives in a paranoid delusional state
where they literally think they're
fighting in la resistance against the
Nazi you know regime or whatever and
it's a psychotic it is regular people
however are just convinced because the
celebrities are cool and Trump is dumb
that's what you got to say to be cool so
then when I come back with a
counter-narrative like I'm successful I
got my own skatepark dude like we
recording music where have you been
where've you been you're the one who
missed the train make them realize that
the reality is there's an illusion it's
like a curtain over everything in my
opinion when I get hit up and I and I
mean this and I'm not trying to say this
just to brag like when I literally get
hit up by like a rock star very very
famous celebrity musician being like I'm
so glad you're saying what you're saying
and then I get angry and I'm like why
won't you say something I'll lose
everything owes my career I'm like
whatever man
when I hear that I'm like I know what
real life is I know what regular people
are interested in and it's not this
weird fanaticism yeah
it's just that as long as no one is
speaking their mind and saying
calmly and politely I'm actually not
okay with that all right I'm not we
don't do that here right yeah as long as
no one's doing that then the wotus is
perceivably the mainstream and that's
what they're counting on and that's what
they threaten you with violence
that's what cancel culture is for to
make you schedule lose your job yep I
got people hitting me up non-stop people
that I've known for a while they're like
it's emotions they're emotionally
triggered and screeching at me and I'm
just like do you even hear yourself what
you're saying to me they tell you don't
you know and I'll try to calmly talk to
them like okay this is this is what led
me to think these things and the reason
I think this and you know can we chat
boom no longer friends
I can't even contact them anymore it's
like Barra
my guess that's the way it is like they
don't want to hear it
yeah what do you got there yeah so I
think it really gives you a leg up to
have thought through everything that you
think yep I think it's a huge advantage
because they don't yeah that's right
when you ask them why do you think this
they're like well I saw a headline once
somewhere and you're like well I
actually read the article and it says
the opposite of what you're arguing yeah
so maybe worse than that they they go
here's the article that proves you wrong
and I go okay let me let me dive into
that sure I want to be proven wrong
right you know I love it I want the
other side of things read it it doesn't
show me anything yes your opinion okay
so and I show that to them and then they
they don't like that thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you